yeah hey everybody its Jessie welcome to
live coding with Jesse and Happy New
Year's and is my some of my kids wanted
to say hi
so here's Cordelia who got blue dial
over her face and this is Ambrose yep
your blue guy on you all right so
[Music]
everybody know unless you've been
waiting in the chat for a long time so
thanks for waiting so long let me know
how the stream is analytics look ok so
I'm guessing the streams okay I'm gonna
get the chat up somewhere where I can
see it easily let's move it over to the
screen ok cool alright so I haven't
streamed in a while it's good to be back
I see there's a lot of you in the stream
I'm gonna do my best to try to respond
to what you're saying but I'm not gonna
try to follow along with a stream in
real-time what I'll do is I'll set a
timer a Pomodoro timer of 25 minutes
every 25 minutes I'll take a break and
I'll make sure I'll take a thorough look
at the stream and try to answer
everybody and then during the 25 minutes
we'll mostly do coding I'm gonna be a
little bit laid-back here so if you're
watching this recording I definitely
recommend putting it on you know like
double speed because it's New Years and
we've got a bunch of time to code it's
still about three hours until the new
year here in the Eastern time zone so I
got a while so I'm not gonna try to rush
and
I see a lot of your saying happy new
year
see if you say like the kids are cute so
thank you and awesome so for a lot of
you that's already 2020 that's cool yeah
here in the in the Eastern time zone in
the United States it is still 2019 where
we're behind here so yes II would you
see on the screen is not the project
that we're gonna work on I just want to
make sure all my stuff was up-to-date
beforehand so I just did an update and
this was the last thing I had open which
was the react native heat sink storage
package that I had done some work on
which I did livestream a little bit of
that with those recordings are available
either on free code camp or on my
channel I can't remember but I'll link
to my channel and my social media stuff
is in the in the description of the
video so feel free to reach out to me if
anybody has any questions about what
what I'm doing today see I try to get
try to get a window up here so you can
see what we're working on here go do did
you steal a protein bar so alright you
do want to you want to play down here
you don't have to sit here and watch the
code you can play do you want to go play
you want to watch the code alright
that's cool
watch the code alright you're being good
so good job okay um to us you want to
say hi my wife's down here trying to get
the kids upstairs come and say I my wife
codes too she's uh she's a react
developer and she works for an agency
called sprockets come on and say I she's
on pretty famous on Twitter
a lot more followers than a wave I they
can see all right cool so let's get a
project up here now we got I'm planning
on my coding until 2020 comes so that's
about three hours for me so we
definitely can work on a few different
things if we want I was thinking of
working on the projects for the free
code camp curriculum I had by chord area
can you shut the door please Ambrose all
right good boy thank you bye-bye is the
kids it's the kids bedtime so hey they
actually should have been asleep already
but they wanted to stay up and be on the
on the live stream so all right so
anyway what was I saying
okay there's a project for free code
camp that I've done some live streams on
before they're basically we want to add
in the free code camp curriculum or free
cooking org we'd like to add in some
react native lessons that you can do
right in the browser but there's it's a
little bit tricky to get react native
code to run in the browser you know you
got to do some basically you got to
change some stuff with it to get it to
run so that was the the goal was to
basically make an in-browser editor for
react native code that would display the
results of your code immediately so
anyway so we found just to bring you up
to speed
we found a library that kind of does
that already and we're trying to modify
it and get it to work within free code
camp so we can try to work on that
there's
a few other projects that we kind of had
going in the past with different live
streams so we had like a react native
math game for kids that we were working
on that we never really finished so
there's a variety of things that we
could do we'll see how it goes so I
believe I do have the project already
pulled down on this machine though for
the react native like in browser editor
so let's just try that for now let's see
where I'm at here I'm gonna go let's
make sure you can see this yeah all
right let me know with the fonts too
small and yeah well this is ton of stuff
in the chat so I know I'm gonna miss
some stuff I apologize in advance
there's just like too many messages to
keep up with let's see
yeah just a lot of Happy New Year stuff
all right cool
let me go like this window we fund this
project so we have a sink storage oh we
also have another react native app that
my wife's been working on that we could
work on as well so I guess we we do have
a lot of stuff we could work on she's
working on an app to help women who are
having a postpartum like depression it's
to help them so yeah all right native
browser editor yeah that's the one Oh CD
Brad browser there we go all right so
we're here let's go code dot to open it
up and it's own vs code window will
close this window out so I am using
Visual Studio code as my code editor
this is what I normally use so if you
don't know me I am a senior software
engineer at Dick's Sporting Goods and I
work I work with reacting react native
everyday I'm gonna open up a can I have
an energy drink here to keep me awake
during this coding session so for my
earlier live streams I used to drink G
fuel and try to get a sponsorship all
the time but it's been 22 years G fuel
and I've gotten no sponsorship so now
what is this one
rain rain if you're out there get
sponsor me for coding last year's okay
[Music]
project that is life says catchy code
without energy drink oh yeah I
definitely can but it's past my bedtime
so I figured this would help it would
also help me to be a little bit more
lively for for the live stream all right
so let's check this out and see what we
have going on here I believe what we
have here is just a create react app
project yep that's it so we have a
create react app project and the goal
was this was a proof-of-concept you're
gonna try to take that library that I
talked about and pull it in to this
project and get it to work in this
project so let's let's just start things
out with a with a start so actually you
know what let's do yarn just to make
sure we have all the packages which we
do and now let's do yarn start see if a
project runs all right and we have an
error
okay so let's work through our error
here and I forgot to start my forgot to
start my timer
okay
all right I got a timer since I forgot
to start it I'm not gonna go to the full
25 minutes before I stop the timer and
go back to the to the chat here so let's
see all right let's check this check out
an error here looking at a preset fellas
are not allowed to export objects only
functions all right then let's see where
our issue is
oh okay all right it's not in turn here
[Music]
right
let's see I remember now the last time
we worked on this on a live stream we
had a ton of errors because we tried to
upgrade a bunch of packages and it just
wasn't it wasn't working out for us
I believe the library that we're pulling
code from hasn't been updated in quite a
while so I think that's where we kind of
left it last time was that we worked
through a bunch of errors but we still
didn't get it to work which that really
worries me right I don't like to use
libraries that have been updated in a
while and in fact let's let's let's
check out the library now see if there's
a newer version that we can pull it
might solve some of the issues for us
and even if it doesn't at least you all
can see what the what the library is see
pull this in let's go to github and I'm
not signed into github what I guess I
don't have to be signed in I can just
search oops I meant to do that search in
github this is the
users I think this is the dude it did it
that's it
yep this is it
okay cool last came in on June 17th 2009
okay it's been a while it's been a while
I'm not like the most out of date thing
I've ever seen
you can see what this is here let me
make this a bit bigger just to like get
a visual of what we're attempting to do
here so you have code over here and then
it displays here as you can see like
it's like real-time editing so that's
what we wore but this does not look like
what happens on free code camp in terms
of like the free code camp UI so we want
to be able to modify it to work in that
way
so essentially like basically like
package this so it can be inserted into
something else like add another project
another you know like basically turn it
into a package that can be pulled in
right so that's the goal see what the
latest release number is see like it's
not like alright so this would have been
the very latest change for you to of
eight
which I don't know that we have the very
latest thing in our project or not ours
might have been a little earlier than
that let's do a git log there we go
Friday August 16th okay
so if the initial commit from this was
August 16th I think we're good I think
we have whatever the latest stuff is we
have the latest stuff okay
it's hey Michael curls here how's it
going Michael Michael I watched one when
I used to livestream way more regularly
he always watch the stream so good to
have you here Michael you are correct I
did have a web player directory which I
believe I just pulled down like
everything that was there I think it
might not be a bad idea to just check
that directory out let's see if it
basically like see if we can get it
working if we can get it working locally
and go from there since at this point
essentially like we took a big risk in
the last stream with this where we
upgraded a bunch of packages at once we
knew it was a risk took it anyway and
gotten ourselves to a point where like
we've worked through a ton of errors and
you're still getting errors right might
not be a bad idea to just go back and
start from a working point and then be a
little bit more incremental about things
so let's do that
[Music]
yeah
native
website okay there we go
all right cool so here's our react
native web player which I have probably
forked this repo and then cloned it
let's see the log they get look get love
and yep
June 17th which I believe was the date
of the last the last version that we had
here so we should be up to date and so
let's run this let me check the
package.json to see what the what this
is to run start so we can do this using
yarn
alright this project is using yarn so
let's run yarn make sure we're getting
all the stuff okay lots of stuff going
on here
a Happy New Year everybody
a lot of new people doing in the stream
welcome all right cool
morning you reckon it would play yes all
right so we had a warning warnings are
okay errors are not okay but warning we
might still work so let's do yarn start
see if we can get this to run well so my
timer is about to run out that I set to
kind of give me give us a little break
so well this thing tries to start up
local SAT let's let's click the link
here sweets it's working it doesn't look
look yeah let's make sure it works nice
okay so we have a working place to start
from I think the gold next would be to
come in take a look around see what we
can get away with in terms of like just
packaging this thing what what I want to
do is be able to keep the functionality
of being able to type here and have
stuff appear here without necessarily
keeping the UI elements right
I want to strip away some of this so
that we can instead do it more of like
the free code camp style like keep their
their UI and all that right let me know
if that makes sense or not all right I'm
gonna set a little five-minute time I'm
gonna go to a live chat and there's a
ton of stuff in the chat so usually I go
to the top and work my way down but this
time I think I'm gonna do it differently
and just start at the bottom and work my
way up with the chat cuz
there's just so many messages but I'm
gonna try to go through some messages
and just answer some questions here feel
free to ask any questions if you haven't
let's see
it's
a lot of happy New Year stuff so I'm
just gonna give a big Happy New Year to
everybody hey let's see I just realized
that if I start from the bottom will
work my way up I can't follow the threat
of conversation so that was a bad idea
so I'm gonna scroll up a bit and go go
back down
michael says while the kids are getting
big plus a beard yes I have a beard the
last stream I I think I did not have a
beard so it's been a while been growing
out the beard yeah and the kids are
getting big it's insane they just keep
growing
skinny Slim's his wool coating family
yeah coating family well I mean me and
my wife coat the kids are still a little
young for it try to get him into a
little a little bit but we'll see maybe
they'll get into it too one day Joey
says it's been a long time since I've
been able to catch from these live
streams well I'm glad glad you can catch
this one
good to have you man Wow there are
people from all over a lot of people in
the stream are like shout not where
they're from and that's just awesome we
have people from all over the world
also let me know if there's any
weirdness going on with like the
background noise or anything like that I
tried to turn off everything I could so
that nothing would make noise here I
turned off my fish tank pump my heater
in my house like everything is off so
hopefully was a better experience the
last dream I know there was some
background noise from my my furnace
revision I know Murphy she isn't here
anymore I think I saw somewhere that
they had to leave but says what is free
code camp gonna do Java for beginners
object-oriented programming design and
coding I don't know if there's any plans
to do like a curriculum on free code
camp org but we frequently have video
tutorials so there may already be a
video tutorial of some Java stuff and if
there's not a video tutorial if anybody
out there would like to create one you
know let go corns or Quincy no probably
the easiest way to get ahold of them as
may be like through Twitter let them
know and you may be able to get the the
tutorial on free code camp
mr. potato excuses my name is Jessie
awesome great name
let's see
let's see someone asked what programming
language is that it's JavaScript and in
particular we're working with react XG
and snowball says I want to a
penetration test which where should I
start
for penetration testing that's not
really my specialty I know there are
some free lessons out there it wasn't
like oh a wasp is that what the I'm
gonna have I mean think about that maybe
in you back you if I can remember but
the secure like information security
team where I work
they did a cool like capture the flag
thing and had some good resources it was
a couple of months ago so I can't
remember exactly what it was but if I
can remember it I'll let you know in the
stream some free resources where you can
learn more about penetration testing
okay all right one more comment and then
we'll be back to the code and word oh
says thank you for everything you taught
us this year I wish you all if get
success in life I really appreciate all
your time and effort I've learned a lot
you're blessed thank you
thank you so much that's really awesome
thanks for saying that thanks for
watching that's cool I'm glad I'm glad
you appreciate it
alright cool I'm gonna scroll back down
here actually what I should do is make a
note of where I left off
yes and I was afraid my kids stole all
the pens they did not my papers
all right I'm just gonna mark down where
I left off at in the chat so I can get
back to it easily next time cool okay so
back to the code right now we have this
running locally which lets us type in
react native code and see our results in
the browser behind the scenes this is
using something called react native web
which converts react native code into
something that a browser can handle and
it's using it basically in a like a
serviceworker which is a file that can
run in the browser and do stuff I guess
kind of like off the main thread of the
browser so let's check out where that's
happening because that's kind of where
where all the magic happens
with this yeah this is it that's where
all the magic happens so let's say we
want to look so I believe it's this nope
not that maybe a babel worker so this is
what is doing the transformation i
believe
yep that's it so things that normally
happen in node on a user's machine on
like on a computer we're now trying to
get to work in a browser in this file
right so it needs to work a little
differently than it normally works but
this is what's what's doing the the work
here so we need to at the very least we
need to keep this intact in and let it
do its thing okay a lot of the other
stuff check out our babel RC right it's
it's not super complicated in terms of
what Babel stuff we have in here we're
checking out a few of these other files
just to make sure we're not missing
anything in terms of like core
functionality
[Music]
okay all right so let's find let's kind
of like go down into this here and see
we're importing this sandbox component
so in components player sandbox
let's just say okay
all right so it looks like there's a lot
going on here as well that we'll
probably need to keep
okay slow frogs
there we go okay there's where we're
actually pulling in react native web
okay
all right now the workspace itself this
is a lot of the like the the UI and this
for the most part I believe can can be
changed
okay
so if we could keep actually the console
part is what I'm the editor sorry the
editor part is what I'm worried about
most
okay all right looks like some misses
there is a lot of background noise let
me see
you know it that might be it might be
the bubbler thing in my fish tank let me
turn that off and see if that helps
thanks for let me know okay that to me
at least it sounded a lot better when I
turn the bubbler off I didn't even
realize the thing was that loud that was
kind of a newer addition to the fish
tank so cool
hopefully that's better all right you
tell you what I'm I'm a little bit I'm a
little bit torn on this one but I'm just
the reason I'm torn like I'm not sure
that this is gonna be a great project at
least right now to livestream because
there's a lot going on it seems like
there's gonna be a lot of work where I'm
just gonna be reading through this code
trying to figure out what everything is
doing which won't make for a great live
stream you all let me know I mean
normally I just I would go through it
it's fine but we do have multiple
projects that we could switch to that
would be um a lot easier I guess the to
actually like get some code written like
we haven't actually written any code yet
so anyway I'll give you all like like a
minute or so I know there's some delay
in the stream so I'll give you a minute
or so put on a live stream should we try
to like stick with it and just like try
to tear this code apart and figure it
out or maybe I'll do some of the work
like on my own and then come back to a
later live stream whenever it's time to
actually do some coding and then we'll
just switch to some other stuff let me
know I guess so
let me check really quick too while
you're deciding and see what I have
already installed all right so we have
si do have the app
to have my wife's app already available
that we could work on I could definitely
pull down a copy of the the game that I
was working on
yeah we got some options
all right I got some responses let me go
through these response to see what y'all
think
Connor is asking what is this code
output the the main output is it's it's
outputting like HTML based on the input
of react native code it it transpires
that and outputs it into HTML that can
be displayed in the browser
I said earlier that I'm torn what I
meant was I am I was conflicted like I
just I really wanted to get this to work
for the sake of free code camp but now
that I'm going through more of the code
I just see that maybe it's not gonna be
the best thing to livestream it just
won't be I don't know it's there won't
be anything to see happening on the
screen you know what I'm saying so I
just don't think it would be that great
for a live stream so okay do something
graphically interesting make a website
do some beginner stuff do JavaScript
okay so like come back to this project
later Samuel says might be unrelated our
my suggestion is make a music visualizer
that you're happy with actually that's
really cool I'd only go do that cuz I
just I have no idea where I would start
with that that's gonna take some
research on my part but that's a really
cool idea because I would love to have a
good music visualizer that would work
with IU Spotify all the time to be a
great dad one that that's awesome that
works or Spotify
Levi says can we get a mini flexbox in
grid tutorial I can definitely do
flexbox I'm not great with grid but
react native users flexbox so I am
pretty familiar with flexbox Carrie says
we have nothing to do so we're just
thinking out with with you watch
cool Levi says do the game Connor says
is it hard or is it just not beneficial
to peace through the code yeah I just
think it would be I mean I just I kind
of think it would be kinda boring to try
to peace through the code at this point
michael says go back to the math game
there seemed to be some beginners okay
and that's a good intermediate project
alright cool let's do tyler asks can we
work some vanilla JavaScript the
projects i have right now are at vanilla
JavaScript but like within react we'll
be doing some stuff that would work as
vanilla JavaScript as well okay Connor
says I understand that can you do can
you show the web page less app then this
is the project like like what is the
code like your website for gaming or
what I'm a software to myself right so
the the website for this particular so
this is the website for that code right
you like you put react native code in
here and it pops up here and I wanted to
take this and convert it so that we
could put it into the free code camp
website and have it work and look like
it should for a free code camp lesson so
that's kind of what I was what I was
trying to do okay
all right cool let's uh let's grab
whoops let's grab that project so I'm
not signed in so I'm just gonna have to
search for myself my jy goal or my jry
go I think I'm Jo I know let's see no
oops
all Oh get up my chessy way I don't know
if I get up name is area just hear how I
go all right cool so battle math is the
is the game that we're working on battle
math here let me put the link in the in
the chat so I just posted the link to
the github repo in the chat so you can
check it out if you want and it's been a
while since I've been in this project so
hopefully I think I have some of the HTC
is now I want to clone it with HTTPS all
right let me type in my github password
real quick I'll find out what it is
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I have LastPass and it I
have this really long password right
which what they recommend and then you
have to go in it's like two-factor
officer bear with me for one second I
[Music]
had intended to get all this set up and
working before the stream but then my
kids wanted me to cuddle with them
before bedtime so I did that instead
like but this should be working now
github son in what I have to factor off
on github alright gives us good to have
two-factor authentication all right now
I can clone this with my SSH key there
we go alright so let's go back here and
I'm in my projects director it's just
what I want to do so I'm gonna do a git
clone and paste in what I just copied
from github cool so now I should have
battle math yep so I could CD into
battle math and open up vs code let's
close this out and let's close
where's the other one that oops I want
to try to keep the as many windows
closed as I can just so that I don't
make the stream lag by having too much
stuff going on at once
let's get our terminal open here and
we're gonna do if I have yarn going on
this project I like to use yarn but if
you want to use NPM instead like it's
they're basically equivalent at this
point alright cool so that's installed
let's do yarn start let's double check
that that's in fact the right command
where we a package.json yep yarn start
so this project is using react native
web so we're writing react native code
but running it in the browser there we
go and here is the game the math game so
click over here this math game if I get
it right so three plus one equals four
oh we need to first things first let's
give this looking better cuz you can
barely even see that right we need to
change the the text color on that thing
I submit that right then these enemies
here on the right hand side go away if I
get it wrong the enemies more enemies
come here's my little hero character
over here so you can see there is a ton
of UI work that needs done we also have
subscribed subtraction multiplication
division alright so we have several
modes here so let's let's get to you I
cleaned up a little bit Levi says this
game could use some CSS that is a true
statement okay so yeah let's let's at
least get the font color in here and the
font size to match what we have here
that'll be much easier to read so let's
go to our code
so it shouldn't be too complicated at
this point is everything still in one
yeah it's all basically in one component
at this point so we have our fjs so you
see we are using hooks so react so if
you're not familiar with hooks you'll
you'll get a little bit more familiar
with it now so we can use functional
components and hooks in react if you're
not familiar at all with react it's a
JavaScript library that helps you to
build apps so this if you don't know
anything at all about react it's gonna
be a bit confusing all right we
definitely got a lot to do here so you
see how we have this SVG in here now
this isn't it would not work on mobile
so we definitely want to we want to do
something about this right but we want
to find that that input so I'm just
gonna do a control fine let me make the
text the font size a bit bigger just
want to make sure everybody can see to
give us enough space as possible so type
in input area so answer input here so we
do have a style for styles input let's
go to that and where's that us we have
our Styles down here now in react native
you can do your stop one way to do
Styles is using this stylesheet create
that comes built in with react native
and your Styles end up being a
JavaScript object so a lot of the naming
will be familiar to those of you who use
CSS but you're gonna have everything
camel case instead of hyphenated so just
slightly different also all of our
values are unitless you don't see any
like pixels or anything in there
so slightly different and where
everything is by default display flex
and it's flex Direction column by
default it's a little bit different than
normal all right where was that input at
okay so the input height with border
Cove and we're gonna left let's see if
we can just give the input like color
and let's just give it white so if we do
FFF hashtag FFF that should give us the
right color and then our font size we're
gonna try to match it with our our math
text so let's give it a font size of 40
all right let's save that legacy linter
options in UVs code settings they're no
longer being used okay let's just remove
the settings all right
now let's check out our app where we add
there it is cool a net nice so we now
have our answer text in our input is the
same size as the rest of the the text
and the same color wonderful okay cool
my timer is about to run out so I will
take another 5 minute break and go back
to the chat let's see and but the next
thing that we'll work on is I want to
show you how to make a file that will
run conditionally basically we're going
to pull this SVG out into its own file
and we're going to make sure that one
version of it runs on
and one version of it runs on web so
that'll be the next thing we do all
right
take a short break let me scroll back up
to where I left off which was a while
ago
and actually I did miss so unfortunately
what happens in my chat is if there's
too many chat messages it cuts them off
so I can't go back so I can't get all
the way back to where I left off
apologies if I miss your message but
I'll try to get as much as I can see
mama says Jessie first time I'm wishing
you a happy new year 2020 dude pure love
from India thank you so much I really
appreciate that
skinny slim says what advice do you have
for someone that's just learning to code
and this was a question wasn't just for
me this was for everybody out there
so feel free to add your advice into the
chat I would say try to code a little
bit every day all right even if it's
only a half hour everyday just try to do
a little bit every day and just just
keep at it right if you can do more than
a little bit that's awesome but just try
to keep to a little bit every day
Stephanie asked what time is it in
America on the East Coast in in America
in the United States it is 9:56 p.m.
trying to there's still a lot of happy
new-year messages a Happy New Year
trying to skip through and find find out
some questions here act Akshay Kumar
says I love free code camp lots of free
stuffs they provide love you guys we
love you too thanks for the message
that's awesome yeah and it's not like I
am I just do a little bit I do the live
coding stuff there's a ton of other
people that do a lot of work with free
code camp so actually they just came out
with the top 100 contributors list so if
you check out like the free code camp
blog I believe it's on there if you
check the free code camp Twitter it's
probably one of the tweets that come out
within the last couple days but you can
see a ton of the people who are or have
been recognized for their contributions
so check that out
hey Gwen Faraday is joining the stream
not sure if you're still here but she
says good to see you streaming again it
is definitely good to be streaming again
I'm super happy about it and Gwen's
actually streaming a lot not too used to
check out her stream it's a Faraday
Academy so check her out on Twitter and
she always posts what she's gonna do
streams and stuff so she is a free kill
camp contributor as well she's the one
who initially even gave me the idea of
attempting that project we were working
on it first because she's not a ton of
work for a react native curriculum so I
really hope that we can actually get
that working and out there to you soon
not found us why are you programming
today I'm assuming you're asking because
like it's it's a holiday right well to
be honest the reason I decided to to do
this today I I just remembered maybe
like four or five years ago Quincy used
the founder of free code camp did a live
stream on New Year's Eve and I remember
all the kids were already asleep
my wife is asleep
was on my exercise bike in my basement
and I've turned on the free code camp
livestream it was watching it while I
was exercising and I remember just being
like thinking how cool it was that
Quincy had done this inmate free code
camp and how much it helped me out and
that was the first exposure I had to a
live stream about coding and then a
couple years later when I actually
started live coding and then ended up
live coding for free code camp I thought
back to that and I thought how crazy is
it that I'm live coding for free code
camp when the first live stream about
coding I saw it was a free code camp
live stream so I thought wouldn't it be
cool to do another live stream on free
code camp so anyway that was my that was
my thought process behind it I also
figured like a my my wife wanted to go
to sleep early she didn't want she
doesn't like to stay up late my kids are
gonna all be asleep you know I may as
well do this so anyway that's why I
decided to to code in live stream today
just so you all know none of this code
that I'm doing today is for my job so
I'm not like my employer is not
mandating that I work on New Year's Eve
this is all just fun side-project stuff
so anyway so that's why I decided to do
today thought it would be cool so didn't
get to through too much of the live chat
on that one but I'll go back to it
anyway let me set my Pomodoro timer
again I may end up taking like the
ending of the stream because there's a
lot of messages in the chat so I may do
like I don't maybe like the last hour of
the stream I'll just stop get through
all the messages I can and then if I get
through everything then maybe I'll do
some more code but just don't leave you
all hanging
when you've liked when you're asking
questions and stuff alright cool so next
thing we're gonna work on is this SVG
right so I'm gonna copy and paste this
SVG so an SVG is I believe it's a
scalable vector graphic is what it
stands for it's an image that actually
like you can represent as code in your
project which means you can do some
really cool stuff with it right so each
one of these paths and stuff this this
these all represent different things in
your image so you could control all
these values like Phil would be like the
color right and even more than that all
these means something right in the image
so you could use CSS and JavaScript to
control these values and change them
based on what the user does to do some
really really cool animations and things
on your page so I know what's her name
Sarah Dresner she's pretty active on
Twitter she does a lot of cool stuff
with SVG animation so if you're
interested in that kind of thing try to
find her on Twitter I think her handle
on Twitter is Sarah IDO but anyway I've
seen some cool stuff done with it so
it's definitely I prefer using SVG's
when I can and instead of having
actually load an image file like it's
just code right here so so much faster
but anyway we're gonna take this which
I've copied and we're going to make some
files here so right now everything is in
source I don't really like that let's
make a folder for components make a
little bit more clean components make
sure I spelled that right and I made a
file not a folder so let's delete that
and let's go back and make a folder
components and then for now I'm just
gonna put the SVG's right in there
usually in a project if it starts to get
big and I have a ton of components and
svgs and all that I'll split it out and
have like separate folders for
everything but for now we're still small
so I think we're fine
no sense in like over organizing things
ahead of time especially because vs code
will pretty much switch all the imports
for you it's really easy to switch to
like reorganize stuff later on so in our
components folder I'm gonna make two
files one is going to be called let's
see what we should call this let me see
what this is a hero
let's call it hero dot OBE I thought I
was using typescript for a second here
dot Jas I actually do want to switch
this to type script I've been using
typescript at work a lot and now I'm
used to it and I really like it when we
did this project I wasn't using it yet
so let's make another file and listening
this hero dot native dot j/s okay and
we're gonna go to let's see if I could
find it
SVG to react I found this cool react
component converter and I use it at work
a lot this is it yep this saves me a
bunch of time because I use a lot of
SVG's and my projects at work like for
icons and stuff so basically what you do
is you just take your SVG code and you
paste it and then what you get is a
valid react functional component so
that's pretty sweet so you get that here
oops let me copy that and let's go back
to our code this would be our regular
hero jsni it just gives us VG component
you know what I wanted to do and I
didn't do let's name this hero SVG I
actually want to name this SVG so that
we know it's an SVG and not a real
component so let me rename this I don't
know what I was thinking
hero SVG yes let's rename this to okay
usually react components are capitalized
so for a native one we can go back to
our converter I can let's go back to our
converter and we can just check react
native and we can see it gives us
basically the same thing but it says
it's react native SVG okay so we're
going to use react native SVG with this
and we'll probably have to import it
because I don't think we have it right
now but this will let us oops do not
copy it yeah yeah we can name it the
same thing
and I don't think we have react native
SVG let's check our package JSON yeah we
definitely don't have it we may only
have a few things it's so nice when you
have a new project and you you package
JSON is this this alone all right let's
pull that in and let's go yarn and
native SVG so now let's go back to our
app dot j s component right and let's
get rid of this giant SVG stuff and
instead we can put in hero SVG as our
component right and we're just gonna
give it a little ending slash there did
we get an auto import yep so my vs code
is set up to automatically put in this
import for us okay so basically it just
said import here SVG from and this is
going to components here our SVG now
what will happen is if we're on the web
meaning in a web browser it's gonna pull
from this file if we were to load this
on a mobile device as an as an app it
would pull this from this native file
okay so an app like a a react native app
on a for a phone cannot use a normal SVG
it'll throw an error so that's why we
needed to do that so the way I usually
deal with that is I always have two
different files for my SVG's that's not
the only way to handle it that's just
how I do it it's it's pretty simple
there are definitely other ways to do it
there may be better ways than this but
this is just how I've come to handle
that now let's let's give this a save
here and make sure it's still working
see yep there we go here's our SVG and
it still works now unfortunately I don't
think I have this to the point where it
would work what you think yeah it's been
a while since I've used this project so
I don't think it'll work right now
because of the the versions that I'm
running basically the version of react
native that I'm using it's too old for
some of the code that we're using
particularly I believe some of the stuff
with hooks so this will not run on a
phone right now until I update the
packages so I don't think I'm gonna
update the packages right now and let's
check our package JSON yeah yeah yeah
this is definitely an older version
should this is gonna show me it should
show me what the latest one is latest
yeah latest version react native for web
is up 2.0 point 12 I want to point 10 so
definitely not not where I need to be
yeah I don't know if I want to go
through the process of updating right
now on the stream also I will say this
if I were building this project from
scratch right now I would probably use
Expo because Expo now has react native
web support it did not have what it was
like very very early on in the
development of ret native web support
when we started this project so we
didn't go with it so I would probably do
this a little bit differently if I
started it now yeah but for now we're
just worried about the web version
on Later streams we will we will
probably get to making it run on a phone
just probably you that are typing over
there
I got about 13 minutes before I'm gonna
go back and answer some more questions
so hang in there I will get back and
answer some questions and see all right
let's see what we work on next
so also if you see anything that's like
wow you should definitely change that
let me know I'll I'll take suggestions
on what to work on next I know there's a
lot to do we need actually me refresh
this and see okay so that is working I
was just checking to make sure that this
automatically went to this input so if a
kids playing this game like it works you
can hit enter okay so it automatically
enters good oh but you know what when
you enter it doesn't go back to input
all right so here's what we're gonna
work on next right now if I were to put
in a number and hit enter I'd have to
manually go back in and click before I
could put in another number again so I
don't think that's a great user
experience especially for a kid if
they're not used to use of the mouse and
keyboard yet you would make it easy as
possible so I want to make it so that
when you hit submit when you hit enter
it submits and then it focuses back on
this again Levi says the corners look
way too sharp on the images some of the
Comic Sans for life yeah you put Comic
Sans on it all right maybe make the
corners a little bit softer that does
make sense the corners are way too hard
like we're rolling with Comic Sans up
there at the top and then we get these
zero pixel border radiuses that just
doesn't go that's a good
a good observation so we'll so if we're
going to do two things next we're going
to make this autofocus
after you submit an answer and then
we're also going to soften these edges a
bit and make it make a little nicer and
match a little bit more with our font
choice we could probably roll with Comic
Sans so just like throughout I know we
did it here but it's a kids game right
we can you komak sans everything it's
about the only situation that Comic Sans
is going to be here
allowable let me get rid of this I'm
gonna leave this thing up for now in
case we throw somewhere scg's in there
and let's get rid of I'm gonna get rid
of these so we're still we basically we
have everything still in one in one file
right so we separated out that SVG but
pretty much everything else is still
here
in our app dot J s file which is fine
now it's still it's a very small app so
on let's see what happens you should
have on our lots of capacity here we go
on our text input on submit editing it
handles the submit write and we see our
ref here is submit input ref we're going
to need that okay so let's find out
where we do handle submit so handles
submit up here and we're gonna say use
callback
all right we're dispatching oh okay I
see are using here
interesting it looks like we are trying
to focus that
and why's the focus not working there
I guess first let's make sure that this
is actually firing so I'm gonna put
brackets around this so we can do more
than one thing in here we're gonna use
our good old console.log and we're just
gonna say Happy New Year in the console
if that if that runs and now let's go
let's run our inspector will go here and
make this way bigger okay goodness I
don't need it like that there we go
alright so alright that ran so we know
that ran then why is the focus not
working
let's see
[Music]
all right anything about this the kids
say
see if we have a
all right so you have a use effect I
already we could do all right if we
already have this on use effect this is
really weird my next step was gonna be
like all right let's do use effect and
just put a submit input ref current
focus on that too right that's that
should work it obviously didn't work now
what we can do and this is going to be a
little bit overkill right let's so when
you do a use effect and you put this
empty so use effect function the first
thing that you pass in is like what you
actually want to happen all right and
then the second thing you put in is an
array of basic things that it would look
for for changes to run again right so if
you pass in an empty array it works just
like component did mount meaning it just
runs once when the component mounts if
you take this away it runs every time
the component updates so we could do
this and have it run every time the
component updates this is probably not
what we want I'll show you
hopefully it'll actually do what I think
it will and we'll be able to see this so
what would happen is let's just see
actually maybe that is what we want
maybe that'll do it maybe that'll work
[Music]
hmm I can't believe that a work cool
alright that is that is actually what we
want okay so here's what we're gonna do
so yeah we're gonna keep that in there
and we can pull it out of here right
because this will this will run you can
have as many user facts as you want
really this use effect is basically
gonna be our component didn't mount and
this one is going to be our component
did update the equivalent if we were
using the it just slipped my mind
basically like they the old-school way
of doing the react components which is a
class component sorry
can't believe I lost my train of thought
for a second so if you're doing a class
component this would be the equivalent
of component did update alright that's
that's cool let's get that calling to
log out of there we can also get this
out of there I'm not gonna remove these
for now and actually I prefer writing it
like this to be honest with you which is
the same thing so saying
saying I actually we can we can
definitely get rid of this you know I'm
not I'm gonna leave this in though
actually this might be why the solve
this I ran into an issue with another
project before where the focus wouldn't
work unless you did it twice it was
really weird and the way I solved it
there was to set a timeout and run it
again and like basically set a variable
for whether or not something was focused
and then checked that variable and then
saying like alright if it's not focused
then let's do this timeout run focus
again so but basically you had to run
focus twice to get it to work so I'm
gonna leave this in here because if if
that is the case and it's still that
issue then we may need both of them in
here I don't know why it's like that for
whatever reason when I'm using react
native web on the web I need to focus
twice I don't think I need to on like an
actual mobile app but whatever anyway to
do like if submit current submit input
referent and then this ready to use an
if statement this is the same it
achieves the same thing I think it looks
a little bit cleaner you just put these
double hands
I believe it's it's like a short circuit
they call it a short circuit there but
this basically does the same thing it
just says like if this is true then
we're also gonna do this if it's false
it just stops which is the same thing
we're doing here and it takes less
basically you remove the if in the
parens and then you just add in these
two ends so slightly less typing
all right but that's cool so we got that
done next thing we're gonna do is work
on our border radiuses to soften those
up a bit so that was Levi's idea and I
think that was a good idea I think it if
we're talking about a kids game I think
a softer border radius kind of matches
more of the like aesthetic that is used
in most kids apps all right let's see my
time is up let's take another break
let's go back to the chat let's talk for
a little bit
oh this seems like there's still some
noise since you can should consider
enabling noise suppression and windows
mic settings cuz there's still a small
but noticeable noise okay I don't know
I've never heard of noise suppression in
the settings so I will check that out
not right now but like for next stream
in less than the ways is like really
terrible also I know I've been saying
this for a while but like I'm going to
get a soundproof office at some point
built right now I'm just in my basement
and I'm getting in a separate office
I've actually already like paid for a
construction company to do some work I
just have it like set up when that's
gonna happen yet so I paid ahead of time
and I kind of like got a deal on it it
was like this charity thing or whatever
anyway it doesn't matter basically the
thing is like I have put money towards
getting an office a soundproof office
built so that live streams would be
better so it will happen at some point
this year and then it should be better
the noise issue should be better at that
point also maybe I'll get a better mic
at some point as well this is just a
very cheap mic I think I got it for like
20 bucks on Amazon
Craig says hi Jesse Happy New Year I was
told there would be punch and pie
sorry no punch I have I have rain energy
drink and I have a giant bottle of water
there is actually a chocolate pie
upstairs though my wife bought one
earlier so if you can make it to Ohio
then you can have some pie and energy
drinks
Connor says okay cool react native
similar to flutter with the app updating
with the code do you work for free code
camp so I don't work for free code camp
this is just volunteer so I would say
like almost everyone that does something
for free code camp is a volunteer there
are just a few people who are employed
at free code camp so if you're
interested in helping out we're always
looking for volunteers if you have more
time than you have or you have more
money than you have time and you can
always donate as well it's a non-profit
I think it's you can get all the tax
stuff worked out as well because it's
officially a nonprofit but yeah I just
do this just kind of as a side thing
just for free
youngdo it says jesse is great you're
doing a great job thank you I appreciate
that
yeah Quran says how to hack NASA with
HTML I do not know how to do that if
anybody knows how to do that that's
that's pretty crazy and you have a
unique and special skill fix it's 50% of
coders I know let me remember my github
password yeah I actually have no idea
what my github password is it's some
really long random string and I just
have it saved in the last pass so if if
I ever forget my LastPass password then
I would have a problem storms he asked
do you know pre-act
I do not know pre-act I don't pre-act
is a lightweight version of react so I
kind of always assumed that pre-act was
close enough to react that if you know
react you could do pre-act but now that
I think about it I don't actually know I
just assume that I've never seen any
pre-act code so I could be mistaken
Levi says I have no clue if I even have
AG in account or not I definitely
recommend getting a github account if
you're if you want to get into coding
it's a great way well one like you don't
really need an account to look at stuff
on github but it's nice to have an
account because then you could you could
save projects that you like but it's
great for your future employers to see
your code that way if you apply for a
job you can put your a link your github
repos in there and they can see what
you've done so they can say they're like
at my job I interview people coders for
software engineering roles and if they
don't have a github profile it's hard
for me to know whether or not
I should bring them in for for an actual
interview like if I just see the resume
I like it better if I can see their code
first right it doesn't mean that I would
never hire somebody you didn't ever get
up it just means that it's easier for me
to make a decision if I can see their
code so I definitely recommend doing it
even if you're totally new you know just
whatever you're working on put it up
there I'd rather see that somebody is
doing tutorials and putting the code up
there than doing nothing right
or at least seemingly doing nothing
right your get up repository can be like
the proof that you're doing something to
employers anybody can go into an
interview and say oh yeah I'm coding
every day but if you can say I'm coding
every day and I can look at your github
profile and see the code that you wrote
and asked you about it and and say oh
that looks really cool you know that
means a lot more so definitely recommend
that it's free you don't have to pay
anything for it
it's I think every every coder should
have one just for the like for the
little edge it might give you in finding
a job all right cool let's go back to
the code see what time it is I'm gonna
do like one more Pomodoro session of
code and then see where we're at in the
live chat and then I might do like a
long break and answer lots of questions
because I'm definitely getting behind
with the questions here which is great I
love there's so many people watching the
stream there's a ton of questions which
I love unfortunately when there's this
many people questions I don't always
have time to answer them so I'm gonna do
my best to answer all of them or at
least as many as I can
before I finish up so I plan on going
until midnight my time which is in about
an hour and a half if there are some
questions I didn't get to I don't
going into a little bit after midnight
but like it's already past my bedtime so
I may not give great answers the longer
after midnight it goes so it might be
pretty tired alright let's get to it
so our hero so we have our Styles that
we're gonna change here I believe is our
character so right now our heroes and
our enemies are basically just views
which think of a view in terms of react
native code are a div in HTML and so
when you see view think a div so let's
go to our character our character style
so down here at the bottom we have our
Styles object which is very similar to
CSS right now we just have squares we
give them a width and a height but it'd
be cool to give them a border radius and
[Music]
40 here let's see what an 8 pixel border
radius is this is gonna be that's a
pretty large radius but I think it would
fit with with the Comic Sans let's see
what that looks like if you're not sure
what border radius is it's this part
here right so before we had hard corners
hard edges like we have here and now we
have these rounded edges right so it's
definitely a little bit softer little
softer there to be honest we could go
with complete circles let me know what
you all think in there
should we have should these be squares
or should we have circles
I never thought about doing circles
before but now that I see even with this
radius I think what do circles I'll let
y'all answer and then while you're doing
that I'm willing to soften these borders
as well so on this this select box on
this text input and on the submit button
we're gonna soften those borders up okay
we're going to give those some border
radiuses - yeah it looks like we've got
some got some votes for circles we got a
vote for square we'll see where we go
I'll give you another minute or so and
then we'll add up the votes here for
circles and squares and see what we're
gonna go with rows what code oops
all right I should say - I'm on a PC now
I do probably like 95% of my coding on a
Mac so but the PC kind of throws me off
a little bit but I just couldn't
I needed a computer that was like good
enough to do streaming and just to get a
Mac that was good enough for streaming
was just so much more expensive than a
PC so this is the way I route I went all
right is okay our picker I believe is
that select box so let's do border
radius do I want to do let's let's try
to give it eight we'll try to do eight
all around and our input border radius
eight and then our button
border-radius eight so we've got that
and let's see what this looks like and
then I was check out the votes all right
not bad how bad that looks I think that
does look more like kid-friendly
although this district down still has
that's gonna be a little bit more tricky
I think to get a nice radius on there we
might have to mmm have to dig a little
bit deeper into the code here and find
out what we're gonna do with that one
alright so let's let's check it out we
have Circle Circle
okay Levi say and do a box shadow we can
definitely add some box shadows master
Seto says it's okay you have Starcraft
in stock
how did you see I asked I do have
Starcraft the Sun circles Georgia
circles let's see who goes says circles
Phil says aliens do aliens
Nikki for Rio says circles
Joey says Jessie since you're used to a
Mac you might be more comfortable in
Linux and windows
you know what I've thought of that
before I've thought about getting a
Linux system for a while I just kind of
haven't haven't done it yet what time is
it it is 10:40 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time abd Gaming is voted Foursquare a
lot it's so I don't know a beedi gaming
it I mean it seems like you're getting
out voted here I know you typed in
square a lot but it looks like most of
the other people want circles so
okay Joey says you couldn't do radius
zero on the bottom and left right
corners of this drop-down so it blends
in more or like this select yeah I would
definitely Bend anymore it might not
look great though yeah we'll have to see
I'm not really thrilled with how this
looks in general so we may want to do
even more with that circle we'll go with
the majority then all right cool yeah it
looks like most people want circles so
let's see what circles will look like
oops I keep clicking the wrong thing to
get to the back to the code all right so
here's what we're gonna do there's a
character so what we we could do here I
don't want to get fancy I was gonna do
something a little bit fancier but oops
if we do border radius 20 this should
give us a circle so basically whatever
your width and height is of your square
if you just take half of that on the
border radius it'll give you a circle
now what you can do is like basically
make these variables and then just make
this whatever that variable is divided
by two remember because this is
JavaScript right this is a JavaScript
object so you can do math here and
actually like the newer versions of CSS
lets you do variables and stuff too so I
guess you could do it CSS as well but
this is easy enough that we'll just put
20
all right here's our circles Wow okay
this is kind of interesting our hero the
SVG goes outside the circle but I kind
of think that's like a cool effect
though like it's a mistake but it it
looks almost like it's not a mistake I
don't know does that make sense to you I
think it kind of looks cool now I will
say this we shouldn't worry too much
about squares or circles here because my
intention is like to actually get little
characters here so I did have somebody
at a conference tell me that they had
like a bunch of characters made that I
could use for this game for free so I
need to look that up I saved the link to
it and I just haven't worked on this
project since then so we may be
replacing these with actual like little
bad guy characters and heroes I'd like
to have like the user be able to select
what hero they want and have a bunch of
different options and then depending on
what you pick like whether what game
mode you pick in the difficulty level
you may have different enemies so I
think that would be kind of cool to do
but right now like this what we have
Bodega I mean it already looks better I
don't know it looks good but it looks
better oh I forgot we we wanted to
change this like basically everything to
use Comic Sans and see how that looks
let's do that let's
we'll go back here and where we got it
it's coming soon
math texts every comic says actually
what I've done what we could do for now
this will work but if we had a bigger
app I'll tell you what I've done before
is basically taking the text component
and I've made a my own text component
and giving it the styles like the
default styles I want including a
default font and then when I go to
import text
I don't import it from react native
instead I import my own text component
which just uses the react native
component kind of behind the scenes when
it takes the base react native component
adds the default styles I want to it and
then I bring it out like that so that's
probably something that like if this app
gets a lot bigger if I keep working on
it maybe it would switch to that but for
now there's just not that much so I
don't think it's it makes sense to to do
that right now
because they're still pretty small but
and like for the input and stuff like
that it wouldn't make a difference
anyway
same way with the does the button have
text I think I do use the text component
for the button so but for the input and
then what about that picker did I miss
that
yeah here's the picker I'm hoping I can
put that on the picker react native is a
little bit more like restrictive on what
like CSS properties you can put on
different elements so it'll definitely
like let you know and throw a warning or
even an error sometimes if you try to
put the wrong property on something like
if you try to do I think if you try to
do font related stuff on a view
component it doesn't like that I can't
remember exactly which ones
work and don't work but it's not as you
know like in normal HTML like CSS it's
very forgiving right you can do a lot of
stuff and you'll never get a warning or
anything the browser will just basically
ignore it right react native is is more
picky like that it has to be for what
it's doing though in terms of like what
what phones can handle all right let's
see what this does this should have
changed this oh yeah look at that nice
very nice Comic Sans make sure yep that
is Comic Sans we probably could set
something on the input to say like hey
we only want numbers in the input and as
long as we're in a mode where we just
have you know like single-digit
arithmetic we could say that K we only
ever want two digits in here that may be
nice to have I can see it being
frustrating if a child accidentally held
a key down put a bunch of numbers in
there and then you can't even see how
many numbers you have really and you got
to try to backspace them all so that
might be a good a good thing to put in
for now if we add modes later on where
you're doing more complicated math then
we could always relax the restrictions
on it I'm gonna go about about nine more
minutes and then I'm gonna take a break
and answer a bunch of questions so hang
in there if you have any any questions
out there right now let's see this hey I
think we got one of those errors I was
just talking about that's awesome or
warning so invalid props style so family
has been supplied to picker okay and
that's we we can't do that so we're not
allowed to do that
so it obviously worked in the browser
right so like the browser it works
because of the way so react native web
in the background is changing this react
native picker into an HTML select and
you can do that on an HTML select you
can't do that on a picker so this is
something that would work in the browser
but would not work in on a phone so what
we can do is let's check out our code
and see what is picker okay so what we
need to do then is is move this and put
it on a picker item I believe and that
should change it so let's do this the
formatting just got messed up but let's
say we're gonna call this picker picker
text so I think it'll work here now the
problems gonna be we still have like we
need the actual text on the on the
picker which I think should work because
I think it should work because we're
always gonna there's no like default
text on the picker that's different than
the items so I believe edition shows up
so this should work so let's take off
let's take this out and then instead of
us add it in here picker as picker text
let's see if we can get rid of that
warning and then this will be like
slightly less of a headache for us down
the road when we want to get this to
work on on mobile C and we've gotten rid
of the warning uh uh but it didn't work
I messed something up all right let's
see what we messed up so we should I
pick a text font family common sense did
I put that on there correctly Oh style
start pictures hmm where did I get this
picker from it is from all right time to
research let's go to react native
documentation and see what the heck we
could do about this I am gonna check the
chat out real quick to see if anybody
knows what my issue is so picker comes
with react native let's see if it has
something built-in to help us style this
okay test ID enabled mood item style
there we go
we need to use item style
alright this your way alright so what we
should be able to do I hope is say item
style and then give it style stock
picker text and then get rid of that
that's nice I get rid of a lot of
repetitive stuff there let's see if that
did anything nope not yet
so we need
alright fought family it's included
there interesting textiles fish the
outside
Michael creo says check the element in
dev tools that's a good good idea let's
see if the if anything's being added
there I'm gonna have to make this a bit
smaller so I can see what's happening
alright so we have to select so on or
select family it's probably getting
covered up
no that's there okay so it's just giving
us the default system UI and then same
thing here okay
let's just see if we can get an example
to see if my implementation is wrong so
let's do what it was a cold item style
[Music]
there we go
so we get a an issue or it's not working
but what this should give us is an
example Oh item textile did I miss that
was that an option
can I do item textile and said this is
from 2018
hmm I'm gonna try item text out just in
case because if it works it'll be the
like the easiest solution to this even
though it wasn't in the docs now I
didn't work yeah and that's not it's not
recognized okay
style so they're using item style and
they're trying to do font family
but it almost seems like
I wonder I wonder if it doesn't want me
to use let's try this I'm gonna try one
more thing on here before we should go
back to our original idea so let's grab
this again and we can put in inline
styles as an object here and see if
maybe that works maybe like there is
something wrong with the way I mean I
just I find it harder to believe that it
wouldn't work with
reiax implementation of the style sheet
but maybe oh yeah see it's not it's not
working
so
all right so my timer went off I'm gonna
go back and answer some questions now
for this though at least for now I think
I'm gonna go back to I'm gonna get rid
of this for now and I'm gonna add since
we already have basically two styles
listed I'm gonna show you how to use two
styles so if we just put a these square
brackets to make an array and we pass in
an array to the style and we can say
styles dot pick your text as well it
should take both styles and combine them
and that should work we'll get that
warning again let's see we have we have
the point we want now at least in a web
browser so this works like that we get
this warning though now if we get to the
point where we want to run this on a
phone and we still can't find a good
solution what we could do is just render
basically render this conditionally so
what I would probably end up doing is
just saying here in the Styles like if
this is web then add the font family
stuff all right I could say here I could
say it up here I probably would make
more sense up here I guess I would only
add this picker texts class styles if
we're on web otherwise I wouldn't then
it should render on a cell phone now we
wouldn't get the correct text which is
an issue but let's say like worst case
scenario we can't figure out how to add
the correct font at least it would run
right which I think that's kind of cool
about react native and then especially
right native web is that you could very
easily like line by line
all right use this if you're on the web
use this if you're on native and you can
even say use this if you're on iOS or
use this if your own Android see you you
have kind of like that level of control
in the how you want to do things it's
kind of nice because you don't have to
write a ton of extra stuff for each
platform you just tweak it here and
there where you need it
all right cool so let me scroll up and
answer some questions and I'm gonna
allow me to set a timer for myself now
I'm just gonna try to answer as many
questions as possible and actually let
me let me commit this first that way you
all can check out the code on github and
I won't forget to commit this so good
status see what we've changed see yep
that looks like what we've changed
yes code want my vs code file in there
where's my kid ignore there we go all
right so do get add and I'm gonna just
add everything to get add period let
everything we do is status again just to
double-check that we in fact are ready
to commit all these things and will they
get commit em which we're gonna put the
messages and we're gonna say I just
prefix it with feet for feature so let's
say
wouldn't we do ad style updates that's
mostly what we did right mostly just
styling I think so I know we did we did
that SVG thing as well but that'll be
pretty good for now get and then we're
gonna push origin master probably could
just say get push that's four on the
master branch but like when I'm at work
I never push directly to the master
branch right I would normally be on a
separate branch I would push that branch
up and then I would submit a pull
request and that pull requests that have
to get reviewed before it went in that's
more of like the normal way you would
work if you got a team of people all
right but for a solo side project like
this
I shouldn't say solo other people have
already made contributions to this
project and you all can too if you'd
like feel free to fork this clone it and
make any contributions that you want
that's that's awesome
and welcome but you know definitely like
make a separate branch and do it like
that since it's my project I'm just
doing stuff right on the master branch
but just so you know like your own
project it's fine if you're working on
somebody else's project you probably
want to create a another branch and like
at work I can't I can't even actually
push on the master branch just lock down
so couldn't do it even if I I wanted to
alright anyway let's get to the chat and
I've been like squinting trying to read
this chat and it just now occurred to me
like oh why don't I just make the font
bigger up obviously that would that
would be better right
all right Samuel is a question what's
the difference between Jay s and
typescript so Jay s a javascript is not
a strongly typed language right which
means kind of like this is going to be
an oversimplification but basically when
you do something in JavaScript like if
we have a variable in JavaScript we can
just assign it to whatever so I have
this constant right this is a function
ieave trying to make these are actually
all pretty much functions so I don't
have a good example trying to find one
that's not a function that's actually
something other than a function so
basically I could have this constant I
can assign and right now it's a function
I could make another constant and it
could be a string another one could be a
number a boolean write an array and
object they're all constants in other
languages you can't do that
I couldn't just say constant to do that
I would have to say int for integer
right and some wing is I would have to
say exactly how many bits right it would
and I feel like int 32
ready for 32-bit if I wanted to have a
string I would have to say string and
assign it to a string right so you when
you basically JavaScript doesn't require
you to say what type something is when
you declare the variable or when you
assign the variable and here the way
we're doing it here we're actually
declaring and assigning a value to the
variable at the same time we don't
necessarily have to the what typescript
does is it changes that so that in
JavaScript you could assign when you
declare a variable or declare an assign
a variable you tell you put in the code
exactly what type that is
so not only that but there are a lot of
other things like you would say if you
created a function you would say this
function would take in this many
parameters and here's the type of each
parameter that I expect in this function
right and then depending on your your
code editor you might get some really
helpful tool tips that would come up and
tell you exactly what to use right
you'll get warnings in your browser and
in your code editor right if if you
warnings or errors if you try to pass
the wrong type in so that's like I'm
probably skipping some important stuff
but basically that's what it does it
takes JavaScript and it adds on to it to
make JavaScript behave like a more
strongly typed language which would
require you to not only declare your
variable but say what type your variable
is right away so I like it I don't I
don't think it's necessary for every
project but it's definitely valuable for
more complex projects at least that's
been my experience
Oh Oh looks like you already answered
what type script is in the chat so I
should have read along but hopefully
anyway it was it was helpful to somebody
my explanation
Samuel says now I feel embarrassed
asking this as I've never done it before
but I'm presuming that you can't just
copy and paste SVG code into react so it
won't work so you you actually can and
normal react you can and react native
you can't okay so if you look I didn't
really go over this but if you look at
the difference here so let's just do
split-screen here for a second and let's
do one side so like here is our two SVG
right one is a normal SVG and one is the
react native SVG so if you use this
react native SVG library it gives you
components based on what a normal SVG
would have so in this case we have the
SVG component in the path component so
basically you just take what would work
in normal react and an HTML SVG and path
all lowercase and you switch them over
to use these components instead and it
basically works there's a few other
things I believe like with these
attributes that may need to be changed I
don't know if that happened in our case
no and then also it's possible I believe
in HTML things like view box so some of
the attributes would be hyphenated and
you need to change them to be camel case
I don't know if that's all of them or
not I can't I can't remember but those
are the only things that I think you
need to change for regular react but
then even for react native there's not
really a lot that you need to change and
if you use a converter like we did it's
very easy so I actually have been using
converter on anything I just leave it
open all the time I used to do it by
hand with like very small SVG's but you
can see like with larger SVG's it it's
much
faster to use converter but anyway that
was a really good question
trying to find the next question looks
like there's a nice little kind of
conversation going on the chat but no
questions directed towards me so I'm
scrolling down a bit oh yeah just just
to be clear to everybody I am using
react native for this project so I'm
using react native and then I'm using a
package called react native web so that
I'm able to run this code in a web
browser yes so it's it's confusing and
it's probably confusing as to why you
would even want to do that but the main
benefit is you can have the same code
run in a web browser and on mobile
devices like as native apps as well and
potentially on other devices there are
ways to run react native on like as
desktop apps or even on on other devices
like smart TVs I think there's a way to
do it like on as a hololens app but
microsoft hololens app so there's some
cool stuff there's even some other stuff
that I'm not I'm not really familiar
with it I've heard of that you can do
with it so it's pretty it is nice and in
particular for these live streams it's
nice because running Xcode and this the
iOS simulator or the Android studio and
trying to simulate stuff so that I could
show you on the stream it takes a lot of
resources on the computer and it would
cause my framerate to drop so it's not
really doable on a live stream at least
unless you have a really really good
computer so this is a way for me to do
react native on a live stream and still
show you the results so there's probably
going to be a time where I'm going to
like attempt to show you the results on
a phone like on a simulator and just
like expect that the stream is going to
lag a little bit but we're going to do
most
our development in the browser so that
we can have a nicer experience
it's a lot of people are joining in the
stream at different times and saying
hello and Happy New Year so hey
everybody happy new year
I know I keep saying it over and over
again but I don't want to I don't want
to leave out the people coming into the
stream now you know later on Samuel was
asking about the game mechanics of the
game we were playing like what would do
you have a game over like what actually
happens so right now the way the game
works is I believe you will only ever
get like if you keep answering wrong I
think you only get up to six enemies
yeah right now it only goes to six
that's basically because like you can
see if I put more than that they would
start to things would start to get weird
they're already touching at this point
and actually you could tell because
they're circles when we had them as
squares it just looked like one giant
rectangle so this the circles put a
little bit better you can tell that
they're actually distinct so I don't
there wouldn't be necessarily a game
over you would just get to a point where
you would have a bunch of enemies and
you would keep trying you can win the
game if you keep answering the if you
keep putting the right answer in and you
get to no enemies so every time you even
a right answer in and enemy goes away
you get to no enemies and you win right
so that's all I have so far for game
mechanics I I'm not sure that I don't
know that I would necessarily want to
have a game over I think potentially
like it would be better to let the child
keep going and seeing if they can start
to get them right because the more they
practice like the better they would get
yeah I can see that if they really just
wanted to start over they could just
refresh refresh the browser tab and then
maybe like when you win
having the option may be to go to the
the next level
so either like bump up to do double
digit math and set a single digit or
maybe like bump up to the next level so
I don't know I think there's it's still
like the bare minimum a functionality I
think there's a lot that could be done
and right now like it doesn't it's not
like you have your score saved or your
preferences saved there anything like
that so very basic but that's that's
basically what happens at this point and
this is based off of a game I used to
play with my son we would play it on a
whiteboard when he was learning basic
math and we actually called it bork math
like after the orcs in Lord of the Rings
but I decided to switch to battle math
because I didn't want the the Tolkien
estate to sue me or anything for calling
it orc math so we switched it to battle
math and I used to just draw a little
bad guys on a whiteboard and then
manually write problems on the board and
erase them like writing erase the bad
guys so uh-huh that's so that the game
mechanics who were already in use before
Oh Levi asked a good question don't you
need a semicolon at the end of those
lines so if you see the code like I
don't have semicolons pretty much
anywhere so semicolons are actually
optional in JavaScript so technically I
believe there are some situations where
you need a semicolon but I never
encounter those situations like I I
pretty much never use semicolons so and
if I ever really need a semicolon my
editor tells me which like I'm telling
you have almost never encountered a
situation where I need a semicolon so
for me I don't use semicolons I set my
automatic linting to just take them out
if they're in there the way I figure it
is if I don't need it then why add it in
it's less typing if I just don't add it
in so good question
Levi says free code camp lied to me then
about some yeah a lot of the beginner
tutorials will have you put semicolons
in so like technically that is like the
standard for JavaScript is to put
semicolons in but in reality you don't
you don't need it like browsers
understand it without semicolons so
whether or not that was ever intended I
don't know but it's just the way things
are in JavaScript that you can write it
without semicolons and everything still
works
yeah yeah Joey says it's a somewhat
controversial topic it is like yes
writing semicolons or not is
controversial for all of my projects
like if I have control over code styling
the code style then I I just haven't
automatically set to remove semicolons
so usually like people can code however
they want but if they go to commit a
pre-commit hook will run and it will
remove the semicolons so when it
actually goes into the repository it
won't have semicolons so so you can go
to however you want if you want to
contribute to my projects but that's how
it's gonna be now if I'm coding for
somebody else's project and they want
semicolons like I will add semi-colons
in like I'll respect their preferences
but for me I do not put semicolons in
Samuel says silly question but why are
you using react instead of vanilla
JavaScript for this game that's actually
a good question if I were just planning
on doing this in the browser I could
definitely do this in vanilla JavaScript
and it would work and it it might like
it would probably be entirely doable
it's not a complex thing I do it react
native because I would like to use this
on a phone like a mobile phone so react
native will let me turn this into a
native app and like have it on the App
Store and stuff friendly I'm not I'm not
attempting to like sell this or anything
I just think it'd be cool if my kids
could play this on a tablet or a phone
so that's why personally and also like I
I use react and react native at work so
it's like a way for me to try out new
things on something that basically yes
there's no consequences if I try out
something new and mess it up here as
opposed to work it'd be a little bit
different and so this was one of the
first apps that I really used the
context API and react hooks on and stuff
so just gives me a little extra practice
good question
Sheehan says can I know how to write PHP
for phishing attack no a free code camp
is not the place to go to learn how to
do phishing attacks and unless you are
getting paid by a company to test their
security it is probably not a good idea
to be doing phishing attacks
Levi says the twitch emojis are way
better than the YouTube ones off to
check out the twitch emojis I haven't
I'm not on Twitch that often so I'll
check out their emojis and see what it's
like Levi says the chat is more like a
Q&A than a chat yeah it ended up being
more like like a question-and-answer
session Oh Michael good point so he also
says one of the one of the reasons why I
use react native was to see if I could
do it so this was I did this at a time
when using react native web was still
like not very common I don't know how
common it is now but at least in my mind
it was still more experimental like I
just wanted to know like can I use this
with create react app and get everything
to work right so I did I just really
wanted to see if it would work so I had
the idea for this game in mind already
because I'd play with my son but I
didn't I just like never got around
actually doing it and so then it just
kind of combined it with the idea of hey
woods to be like a cool way to use react
native so that's why so I tried it and
then we end up like we use react native
web with react native at work as well so
I believe trying to make what I started
doing first now I don't even remember I
think it was almost simultaneously that
I was developing this and testing it and
we were doing it at work but anyway yeah
definitely not necessary for this
project but it was a good opportunity to
test out some some new stuff I was
learning we have a question about is
rust hard to get into I I've never tried
coding and rust so I have no idea if
anybody knows anything about rust let us
know in the chat
oh cool Levi says the noise is gone now
so I'm not sure what that noise was but
glad it's gone
unreal expert says what type of drink
are you drinking so I am drinking a rain
energy drink this is carnival candy
flavor
I believe I went with carnival candy
flavor because it was the cheapest
flavor on Amazon and I just put this on
my subscribe and save this is like my
pre-workout drink so I don't drink these
every day or all the time I lift weights
three times a week
so I wake up early and I drink one of
these on the way to the gym and that
just gives me a boost a boost of energy
so that's my that's what I'm drinking
also drinking water which I should
probably probably drink your mouth gets
like really dry when you are live coding
because you talk a lot right so anyway I
don't really know if these things are
good for you or not so I just want to
put a disclaimer like I don't officially
like recommend this to anybody or not
like but it it feels like it helps me
get awake in the morning when I work out
and then also like if it's getting late
if I need to drive somewhere late I have
one if it's like an emergency and I
needed energy I have one
mark Shawn says thanks thank you for
coding tonight Jesse I thought I was
going to be alone on the new year but
not anymore oh that's awesome I'm glad
that you're not alone on the new year
that's pretty cool yeah I wasn't sure
like how many people would want to watch
because it's you know new year you know
maybe people would have plans or
anything but that's cool that's really
cool I would have been alone too to be
honest everybody else in the house would
have been asleep so I don't even know I
would either been asleep or would have
been by myself probably checking out
when everybody else was the one on on
social media and waiting for through the
New Year Sammy says I must say like Marc
Thank You Jesse for doing this tonight
oh you're welcome
this is cool yeah well like I said I I
said this at the beginning this dream so
a lot of you probably missed it but it
was maybe like at least four years ago
maybe five years ago I was myself alone
on New Year's and saw Quincy who's the
head of free code camp and the founder
of free code camp doing a livestream and
watched it and thought it was really
cool when I I had done some lessons on
free code camp before and that was like
my first experience with a coding live
stream and years later it I remembered
it and it was like kind of inspiration
for me to get it started and it's crazy
that I'm live coding for free code camp
now on new years and anyway so I'm
really cool that I could do for you all
kind of what Quincy did for me back then
and anyway so it's cool that we all get
to hang out world-changer says how to
donate go to free code camp dot org and
follow the directions on there if you
want to donate to free code camp and I
said that money doesn't go to me
I don't get anything so like we don't
even do ads on YouTube so I'm gonna get
any money for that there's just a few
people that do like very important work
for free code camp like making sure the
servers are running and stuff like that
that are actually paid like I believe
over 90% of us are just volunteers so if
you want to donate in any way in time or
money like that's awesome
Levi says I'd like to volunteer but I
think I'm Way too young free code camp
doesn't accept teenagers do they
I don't think age really matters to be
honest with you I think if you like
there's a lot of different ways to
contribute and so you definitely could
like there's the free code camp forum
this is probably one of the easiest
place to contribute you can just go on
there and be active on the forum there's
a blog for free code camp has its own
blogging platform now so you could post
vlog stuff on there there is a obviously
the YouTube channel then all of the free
code camp source code is open source so
you could set up a profile on on github
and work on some of that code even
little things like writing correcting
typos you know that aren't necessarily
code are still very helpful so there
there's just so much stuff that could be
done there's also like a free code camp
I forget what they call it exactly but
basically it's like documentation for
every different type of coding thing you
could think of so there's a ton of
different ways to contribute and so just
kind of check it out and ladies don't
don't let age you know stop you I think
if you have good good stuff to
contribute then free code camp will
probably want it
check base says do you know some
programming language for cross-platform
iOS and Android
yes actually react native which is
JavaScript base lets you do
cross-platform iOS and Android I'm
trying to think this flutter I'm so kind
of behind on learning about flutter but
does flutter let you do Android and iOS
I know it does Android but does it are
there any flutter people in here let me
know if there if there are if it does
iOS
it's
a savior I'm not sure whether it's
Xavier or Xavier let me know how you
want me to pronounce that I've heard
both so let me know and I'll do my best
to remember and pronounce it correctly
but anyway the question is what if
you've been working as a developer for a
few years we can't put up code to github
to share with other employers can you
not put up code because your employer
isn't open source or is there some other
reason if it's because your employer
that's that's kind of tough that's how
my employer is right now your only
option really is to well I mean you
could get at your employer to do some
open source stuff which may be difficult
or you could do some side projects on
your own which also can be difficult if
you don't have a lot of time to do it I
know like for me I have four kids so
there's not really a lot of time like if
I'm gonna do a side project that usually
means that's less time I get to spend
with my kids so I know that can be
difficult but if there's some other
reason why you can't put code up there
let me know but you know basically try
your best to see if you can convince
your your employer to let you put put
something that your work code on get up
otherwise it's got to be like side
project stuff
so I've been trying to find a question
there's a lot of back and forth here
what is
[Music]
okay I got to the point we were all
voting on circles and squares so let me
just go through that
Ramesh pointed out that the the app
still has the react icon in the title of
react app so yeah I'll definitely have
to change that as well I don't really
have another icon though that I could
put there I don't have a gain an icon
for the game but that's something I'll
have to have because if I want to put it
on an app store at some point I'll need
a little icon so I have to think about
what I want that to be
all right Levi says oh wait no that's
not a question so Sam had to go and I
didn't I didn't catch it if you're still
here Sam
I'll see it probably not still here that
was well
hey still I'm still trying to find
questions there's a lot of like
back-and-forth talking in the chat which
I love I love when you all interact with
each other but it's hard for me to find
actual questions Oh Levi has to go I
missed that too that's the thing about
when I can't keep up with the chat then
I miss when people leave so but anyway
Levi wanted me to know to try to add
border-box shadow around everything so
it looks like it's raised off the page
that that's actually pretty cool a
pretty cool idea I think that's a good
idea
I kind of don't want to get too fancy
with what I do since I'm proud I really
would like to replace what I have now
with like character sprites like make it
look a little bit more like a video game
but I do like I like the idea of giving
it some the appearance of some depth
let's see we have a question does anyone
know if the stream will be saved it will
be saved the stream will be available to
watch just probably just a few minutes
after I end the stream and the project
some questions about explaining the
project this is a math game for children
that we're building with react native
react native is a like a JavaScript
library then it can build we're building
it in a way so they could run in a web
browser or it could run as an app in iOS
and Android
Spence wants an opinion on learning C
for a first language C is pretty low
level I if somebody asked me what
language they should start with I
probably would not say C it there's just
there's a lot of stuff that other
languages kind of do for you that you
have to do manually in C so the learning
curve might be a little bit harder I
personally think JavaScript is a decent
language to start with because you don't
need anything extra to run it like it
just runs in your web browser it is it
is pretty forgiving like you can kind of
mess stuff up in JavaScript and it'll
still run but you can get it to run
other languages like sometimes there's a
lot of compiling involved like you can't
even see what's going on also you can
build pretty much anything with
JavaScript by that I mean like you can
build for a lot of different platforms
with Java scripts look pretty easily so
it's a versatile thing also probably I
felt was if you didn't really didn't
want JavaScript that maybe recommend
Python I think Python is pretty cool to
learn with there's not really a lot of
like special characters and the syntax
so you don't get caught up as much in
syntax stuff so those are just my
opinions on first languages probably
like I did learn a little bit of Java
scripts as kind of my first programming
language but it was such such a little
amount I wouldn't even say it counted
the first time I tried to use a
programming language to really program
something I took a class in C++ so that
was probably my first first language but
that was a long time ago and I just made
a calculator with it and I did a couple
other things but I can't even remember
they were so that's where I'm kind of
coming from with my my
their mark shown says can I use spring
boot and react native together as to why
I'm using spring boot I would be doing a
lot of heavy server-side processing I'm
not 100% sure I know people where I work
you spring boot but I've never worked
with it directly so I'm not really sure
if you could or not I believe they're
people where I work some teams that are
using them both but I guess I have not
100% sure on that we got a question what
do you think about Expo I love Expo Expo
which is exp oh expose wait it's kind of
like a helper library for react native
it makes some react native things easier
than what they would normally be if
you're just using just straight react
native so I love Expo I I definitely
recommend using it for any react native
projects try to use Expo if for some
reason you doing some crazy thing that
isn't supported by Expo then you can
always eject it if you need to but Expo
just provides some really cool stuff
makes things easier it makes like even
even things like just running your stuff
locally it makes that easier
so bundling your app for the App Store
there's a lot of like helper components
that you can use Expo I really like it
especially now that it has web support
as well Expo is definitely the way to go
Michael Creole says for our picker he
says what if instead of a picker we just
made it a button that opens a modal form
with four separate buttons you can add
phone and family to that's actually
that's a good idea
you know the picker is definitely the
simplest way but if we're not going to
be able to do the if we're not even
gonna be able to control the font in the
picker then you know maybe we should go
with something else
Joey says we were talking a few minutes
ago about semicolons in JavaScript
whether you use it or not so I don't use
them Joey says when when so anyway Joey
says I do the opposite I often write J s
without semicolons and have the editor
or ESL and insert them when saving so
for me I always have the editor just
take them out and I never write them
either so you haven't put them in so
that that is that's kind of interesting
actually that would work for me
especially if I'm working on someone
else's project and they want them in
there if I were to just not actually
that is what I do normally I believe the
last time I worked on a project I did
have the editor I didn't have the editor
to do it they had it set up so that like
the project would automatically put them
in so I didn't have to do it when I
wrote the code either so that is a good
way to do it
and Andrew Hillis sorry if I
mispronounced that but says I still use
semicolons because if I ever go to
another language I'm already used to
using them that's true a lot of other
languages do use some a colon so I it is
hard for me to get used to using them
when I do have to use them for other
stuff
Micah also has the editor add
semi-colons in amber Steph says hello
world hello how's it going welcome mow
Hill says what is the Big O of Dijkstra
algorithm tight bound oh I I don't know
enough about Dijkstra's algorithm and
it's Big O notation to answer that off
the top of my head uh-huh so Big O
notation is like a way to measure the
notice I say performance on my
performance just the right world word I
it's a it's a way to measure how
performant an algorithm is both in terms
of time complexity and space complexity
so I don't like that I don't remember
enough about anything like that the only
time I study stuff like that is if I'm
gonna do interviews and to be honest
with you I've never had anybody asked me
about that on an interview uh-huh that's
something I would really just look up
but anyway that actually is kind of good
to remember like it's good to know about
Big O notation and all that stuff but to
be honest like I've never actually had a
question about Big O notation on an
interview so I don't know how useful
that information is in terms of getting
a job but I guess it's good to know
about in case it comes up mark shown
since have you tried anything with
webassembly I haven't yet so I'm like
kind of I read about it when I see stuff
about web sembly but I have not tried it
yet I just haven't really had a good use
case for it yet but it would be cool to
try for those of you who are not
familiar with it webassembly it's
I'm no expert at it but it's a way that
you can use different languages to write
stuff for the browser so like you could
use Python or C sharp or I think
whatever language you want write it and
then have it run in a web browser and
there are some performance potential
performance benefits to doing this so
it's really cool now for me I'm mainly a
JavaScript developer so it's not as
attractive to me like I I know I know P
developers who aren't primarily
JavaScript developers who see this as a
great opportunity because they can use
their main language on the web I kind of
see it as like potentially it's a way to
run do things in the web even faster
than you could otherwise so I just think
that most things on the web right now
don't really need that so I'm kind of
waiting for like that that use case
that's really gonna make webassembly
like a necessary thing so I haven't
found it yet but like I said I'm not
really an expert at it so I think like
it'll probably be a really big deal at
some point probably just not like not
it's not there yeah it's not ready for
like mass adoption yet
Joey says yes see I tried live coding a
while back and I'm a terrible host
you're much better at I don't know I
just keep talking I don't know what I've
also been doing it for a long time this
is like two years of live coding so many
many hours for five coding let's see
Rahman says hi there from Iran hey how's
it going thanks for joining us
ultimate greg's has more live coding
sessions I'm loving it awesome Network
host any area 51 says my house is
already asleep they said they'd hang
with daddy but my son said he wants a
Raspberry Pi to code and network
engineer like me that's cool yeah that's
what I assumed everybody in my house is
asleep I haven't heard any noise up
there it's definitely past everybody's
bedtime oh it's almost midnight here so
it is 11:53 p.m. off to remember to
check this clock when it's midnight
Lonnie bulldozer asked if I'm drunk I'm
not drunk so I did have a drink earlier
before the livestream so my wife my wife
got me everything I needed to make a
Manhattan so Manhattan is probably my
favorite alcoholic drink and it's either
bourbon or rye whiskey with a few drops
of Angostura bitters and sweet vermouth
and then I you put a maraschino cherry
in it I like to add a little bit of the
juice from the cherry you can shake it
or stir it depends on how much time I
have as to whether I do that and then I
like to add a little bit ice in there
too so it's a good drink so drunk not so
much
I would have to have more than one I
think to be drunk but it was just a nice
nice drink she went out earlier and got
got treats for the kids and stuff for
for New Year's
let's see okay so I asked a while back
about flutter if flutter let you do
Android and iOS and it looks like
flutter does let you do Android iOS and
web so that's awesome so I do I I have
talked with some flutter developers
before conferences and stuff so it seems
really cool I mean for what I do like
your act need is my thing so I'm gonna
not really get a switch right now like
I'm in the middle of building a big app
a hutton react native Sochi but it seems
kind of cool we have a question about
unity so does free code camp have
lessons on unity and c-sharp I believe
we have some videos on it I don't think
they're like there's no curriculum on
freak ok org but there are videos about
it on this YouTube channel special elves
are sorry yells capitalist and seem like
it should be pronounced separately but I
guess it's just special is the name says
some people saying flutter is better
than react native yeah I to be honest
with you I don't really know what's
better like so I use react native I
haven't actually used flutter so I can't
really say which one is better I imagine
it's like most things in that you just
need like it depends on the situation so
it depends on like what do you need to
build and what do you already know what
is your team already know stuff like
that
honey bulldozer said you're sweating uh
maybe that's why lonnie asked if i was
drunk
am i sweating to be honest with you oh I
have like like oily skin right like I
don't have any way he deals with it like
some people have really dry skin they
got a you slow shin like I never needs
to use lotion like at the end of the day
I'm just like just so much oil on my
skin so I'm probably look super shiny so
it's a it's really cold and right now
I'm in my basement and I turned off the
heat so the furnace wouldn't run because
it makes too much noise so I'm actually
really cold but because it's the end of
the day like I have this oily skin so
that's probably why I look like I'm
sweating all right three minutes until
the new year where I'm at almost no Ben
says this channel is one of the best
songs congratulations Thanks
I mean I'm only like a small contributor
here but I will say thank you on behalf
of everybody that can show used to the
channel Max Lozano says how do I start
learning Python I don't know what the
best way to learn Python would be free
code camp I don't think we have Python
course we just added something was it
Python I don't know this might be a good
to check out let's check this out
[Music]
I thought we just added something else
I don't know maybe it's not added yet
yeah okay so there are some free like
online coating places where you can
learn Python code Academy I believe has
some free stuff
Udacity has an intro to computer science
course that uses Python that's free so
check those out Kristy Jensen says
thoughts on women and programming I'm
studying computer science sometimes I'm
the only female in my class Oh No well
it's too bad that you're the only female
in your class I didn't go through a
computer science degree so I'm not 100%
sure how things work in computer science
but I do know I think now is a good time
to get into program programming as a
woman my wife just got into the
programming hey it's midnight so happy
new year
just hit midnight here on the East Coast
in the United States so everybody in the
Eastern time zone Happy New Year yeah
I'm in 2020 now like a lot of you what
sing huh so I want to say like cheers I
have like a glass of champagne but I
just have this water bottle so happy new
year so Christy back to your question
the reason I say I think it's a good
time to get in now is because people are
making I think more of an effort to so
number one people are realizing how hard
it has been for women to get into tech
into programming and they're starting to
make an effort to make things better so
for instance when my wife was starting
out she got a scholarship to a coding
boot camp
and she got scholarships to go to
conferences
because she was a woman trying to get
into programming right so there are
opportunities like that for women that I
think can be helpful also you know there
are companies that are actively trying
to hire more women so I think it's like
they're definitely still places where
it's difficult like I hear stories about
that but then also know like my wife has
had a very good experience so far she
didn't have any problem at all finding a
job
she works remote so yeah that's my
thoughts on it like in terms of like
what I'm coming from to is like there's
no intrinsic reason why a woman couldn't
be a good programmer like as good or
better than a male programmer right like
so I don't I don't have any weird
thoughts like that right so but I do
realize that there are some like the way
things are done that some companies
makes it hard for a woman need like just
be there and exist right so I think it's
getting better there are some places
that are better than others in terms of
like just being a a good environment for
women to be in definitely remote work is
remote work is nice not just for women
like it's great for everybody because
like that environment factor is brought
down to a minimum maybe you don't have
to actually be there every day and like
be around people for like for better or
for worse but such a ton of remote
opportunities but then even even then
like those opportunities where just the
environments are getting a lot better so
I hope that answers your question
hang in there in your computer science
classes I know that's that's tough
being I doubt Allah like I just can't
imagine can't imagine that feeling of
number one being female because I'm not
a female right but number two being the
only female in the class so that's tough
I've been like on the other and like in
with my degree is in economics there
were some classes where there was only
one female in the class in economics
classes she would she always held her
own though it was a small group of us
that kind of all had the same classes
but I imagine it probably could have
been easy for her
but anyway hang in there get through it
there's a lot of cool opportunities so
try to take advantage of like the
scholarship opportunities and stuff like
that anyway I hope that was a good
answer let me know if you have any more
like specific questions for that and
sorry if I rambled it is I told you
anytime after midnight my answers are
going to start getting worse because I'm
gonna be getting tired
Sergio says to be a back-end developer
what languages do you recommend learning
first it really depends on what kind of
work you want to do specifically or were
like what companies you want to work at
so if there are certain companies you
really want to work at or a certain
thing you really want to do then you
probably need to do a little bit of
research to figure out like what what
you need right so for instance a lot of
machine learning stuff is done in Python
if you want to do like a lot of cloud
type stuff I believe like if you work at
Google I think go is used heavily for
Google's cloud stuff if you like some
companies are heavily dotnet base so you
probably want to do like c-sharp and net
some companies are very based in Java
some companies use javascript full stack
so I would maybe do your research if you
just want to be back in then I guess it
really if you have no preference at all
it kind of doesn't matter if you at some
point would like to be full stack though
then Java scripts not a bad option
because you could learn back-end and
then also have that experience in
JavaScript to do front-end but yeah it
just it really kind of depends on what
what you want to get into
Samuel says what do you think of using
spring boot and angular together I'm not
really sure but I have not used spring
boot myself and I haven't used angular
in years so I don't know I don't know
enough about either one of them to give
you a good answer
mica says a National Public Radio report
in 2013 stated about 20 percent of all
US computer programmers are female and
open-source fields only 10 percent of
women are programmers oh yeah that's
interesting
I was really interesting I wonder why
that is that it's it's less for
open-source let's just do we need to
learn Jas and laravel I don't I don't
know if you would need to learn it
depends on what you're trying to do in
terms of JavaScript and laravel so maybe
give a little bit more information I can
give you kind of a better answer
sujay says is anybody interested in
google Summer of Code if so what
projects are you interested in I'm not
really sure I don't
I've heard of Summer of Code before but
I'm not exactly sure what it is I guess
I'm I'm kind of interested but I don't
know what what is about mark Sean says
Jesse your explanation of Big O was
perfect including time and space oh cool
all right I guess I still remember I
remember it correctly then
Oh Joey says eBay has an amazing blog
posts about their use of webassembly
highly recommend reading all right cool
I'll have to try to find that we were
talking about webassembly a little bit
earlier and as I'm I am intrigued by
webassembly I'm just waiting for like
what's the practical application where
like they'll be a really good use case
you know mark Shawn says if you check
out web assemblies website there are use
cases all right cool I'll definitely
have to check that out then Joey says
plus one for Manhattan's and old
fashions yeah Manhattan is very similar
to the drink the old-fashioned which I
also enjoyed that so I enjoyed them both
both they're really good drinks if
you're into whiskey based drinks they're
very good Joey says no not shaken yeah
yeah you can I know that some people
have strong opinions about stirred
versus shaken drinks but I used to be a
bartender at one time so I definitely
appreciate the the differences between a
stern and shake and drink but I like to
be I'm going to be understood honest
with you in terms of taste as long as
you don't as long as everything is cold
enough the shaking with ice doesn't
water down too much in terms of taste I
think Shake and drinks are generally
better right because of all the oxygen
in the drink it it does something for
the flavor right stirred drinks are
better for presentation because it keeps
the clarity and I will say there's less
melting so less watering down of the
drink but like potentially if you were
to keep all your ingredients chilled
when you shake it in the ice you could
minimize
the melting and so you wouldn't have a
watered-down drink so like it just kind
of depends like if I was bartending I
probably wouldn't shake it I wanted to
look clear and nice but for myself I
shake most drinks if I want to take the
time to shake it so anyway sorry this is
a coding stream sorry I get off on my
much red screens
say it says what do you think about chat
bus applications and future using
dialogue flow or bot framework etc I
don't have a lot of experience with
programming chat bots I didn't make an
Alexa skill once but I don't know a lot
of experience beyond that with forgive
me chat boss but I'm really excited
about it
I own a lot of like voice chat devices
and I really like it
I used the so that Google has this call
screening feature for your phone and I
really love that so I'm kind of excited
for where that goes to where like chat
BOTS either text base or voice base
become like nearly indistinguishable
from people and like I don't want it to
be like in kind of a weird way where you
don't know if you're dealing with a
person or bought but just in a way where
like I can talk more naturally to chat
bot and do things I'm I think it's gonna
be really cool when I'm looking forward
to it just in terms of like the future
of it and I think it could be applied to
so many things in terms of programming
it I'm not really up on on the best
stuff so like dialog flow about
framework I don't have any opinions on
that I don't know enough about it but I
think that's the way I actually have a
so beyond chat I think brain computer
interfaces are kind of really cool just
like skipping the talking all together
and going directly to reading the
brainwaves so I have a brain computer
interface device that should be coming
in in a few days and I really would love
to do some live streaming about making
applications that read your brainwaves
and do things based on that so hopefully
I'll have more coming soon for that I
wish I would have had the the hardware
for this live stream but it didn't come
in
I think it'll be in on maybe this Friday
hopefully if there's no delays in
shipping
we have a question about so I mentioned
that I was in economics this is how fast
an economist make transition and IT
system field analyst system analyst
field let's say there's truth in terms
of how fast can you transition it's hard
to say like making the transition into
the field is all defense on like how
fast can you convince somebody that
you're to give you a job that you're
ready right so it's really really hard
to say there are definitely people who
take less than a year and make huge
career changes and have good jobs in the
IT field there are people that take a
lot longer it really really depends a
lot on the person where the where
they're living at what the job
opportunities are like so it's just it
would be hard to say but it's definitely
doable like within within a year all
right Christy says thank you for that
response I think you're thanking me for
the response I assumed the time stamps
kind of lined up with what I was talking
about it
you're welcome hope at least hopefully
it was a decent answer to your question
is it hard to learn Java
I only know C and Python if you already
know C in Python I think you could
probably pick up Java the question is ng
Rx or rxjs for angular I haven't used
angular since angular 1 and so I I do
not know a aditya says sorry if I'm
mispronouncing your name says what are
you coding here I just joined in
actually so we're kind of done with the
coding stuff we're just doing a little
question and answer before I wrap things
up but we were coding trim I found my
code we're using react native which is a
JavaScript library to code in
a game just like a very simple math game
to help children learn learn math and we
wanted to run on web iOS and Android Oh
Joey says eBay uses webassembly for
barcode scanning that's interesting
that's really interesting I definitely
want to check that out I'm doing stuff
with barcode scanning as well at at work
so I would I want to know more about
that Joey says no semicolons and shaking
your whiskey sigh sorry Mohammed says
what programming language should I start
in to become a successful software
developer unless you really know what
you want to do like machine learning or
whatever
I recommend JavaScript because that's
gonna let you do front-end and back-end
and it's gonna let you build for a lot
of different platforms there's also the
learning curve for JavaScript is not
that steep and there's a ton of free
resources for it
I have tried to teach myself coding
through various means multiple times in
my life usually ending in failure any
advice for a guy who wants to succeed
but feels too dumb to keep trying I
would say when you're trying to learn
when I'm trying to learn something new
or back when I was first learning coding
the best advice that I could give I
think is just try to do a little bit
every day and just keep going and also
like there are times when you're gonna
feel you are gonna feel like you just
can't get it like you don't know enough
like the more you learn ton of like the
less you'll feel like that or at least
when you feel like that you won't freak
out about it because you'll know it's
normal but there are times when I think
oh wow like I can't believe I can't
figure this out not like my wife went
through in the last year like the
process of learning how to code and
getting a job and so I kind of went
through that process with her of you
know she very frequently thought like I
can't get this right so you're gonna
have those those times when you feel
like you can't do it and you feel like a
failure just realize like everybody goes
through that just keep trying to learn
at least a little bit every day so even
if it's only a half an hour of coding
just keep trying yeah no one I say every
day like if you got to take a day off
here and there that's fine you know like
for me like Sunday was usually my day
that I'm like I'm done I'm like yeah you
know hang out with family and stuff so I
don't mean like it has to be every day
or it won't work but definitely you know
take a day off here there don't take two
or three days off frequently right
you're gonna want to try to keep it up
every day
or as close to everyday as you can it'll
keep things fresh in your mind and like
it'll keep you going at it like when you
feel like you can't do it like the the
just keep going so like having like that
cadence of every day will help you keep
going I think my wife had a streak of
like over 300 days of straight of coding
and that really helped her get through
it because she wanted to keep your
streak going Joey says what which brain
interface device you're getting it's
called the notion so it's a new device
so the company is called neuro City n e
u ro s ity I think it's yeah I think
that's how you spell it
anyway I got a Developer Kit so I think
I'm going to be one of the first people
to get the kit so you can request like
if you go on their website you can put
in your email to get on the list like to
get a Developer Kit so I'm excited about
it it's I haven't used it yet obviously
but it's supposed to be like pretty
pretty accurate and I'm just I just keep
having all these ideas about stuff I
could do like I don't know it's gonna be
cool I don't say too much so I'm getting
really tired I gotta in the stream but I
really hope to be able to do some
awesome stuff and like do some streams
about it
clone colonna's app am sorry for
mispronouncing that says love from
Argentina thank you
Joey says Jesse my first code
contributions to an open source were to
your f us site project
uh that's awesome now I'm a lead
software engineer I said this already
but it got buried before you found it
okay I thought I saw you say something
about this and then I couldn't find it
again
alright I'm glad you said it again wow
that is so awesome what congratulations
on being a lead software engineer that's
amazing and that's so cool oh man I'm
really like I'm I'm so happy you said
that thank you that thank you saying
that twice
mark Shonda says New York or FedEx or a
different company that needs to scan
barcodes I work for Dick's Sporting
Goods so we scan barcodes like in the
store basically so I'm working on a
point-of-sale system that will run on
cash registers so in that context where
we're doing barcode scanning shyam says
how can I stop procrastinating hmm
that's that's really that's off question
yeah so I'm gonna think of like some
type of some type of tricks to get
yourself to stop you could set I mean
sometimes it helps to like set a goal or
just set a time or say like I'm gonna
work on this thing for let's say half an
hour and the timer goes off and you'd
like reward yourself so sometimes a
reward helps a reward and/or punishment
right like if I don't do this much by
the end of the day like then I can't
like no TV or no video games or
something right and it's hard to do it
like to punish yourself
right ha ha ha but or you say if I do
get it done then I get this extra thing
right so maybe something like that
once again says where should beginners
go to start learning
I recommend free code camp org it's a
great place for beginners
kavita says hi Happy New Year 2020 a as
a goin happy new year Patrick Chan says
what is battle math paddle math is a
game a math game that my son and I came
up with when he was learning math as
when he was very young and basically it
just when you get a math problem right
you defeat an enemy if you get it wrong
more enemies come onto the battlefield
so it's just my son really liked it when
he when he was doing that he was really
into Lord of the Rings and stuff and so
like the whole idea of it being like a
battle was was more fun to him than just
doing math problems so I'm trying to
turn it into an app all right I have
reached the end of the chat oh there's
one more question so I'll just do this
one more question and then then I'm done
I gotta go to sleep the last question is
what tech are you excited for in 2020
for me personally feel free to add your
your answers in here as well in the chat
or in the comments but the tech I'm
mostly well the tech I am excited for
2020 is definitely my brain computer
interface that I'm gonna hopefully be
developing for soon super excited for
that I'm also I'm really excited for the
companies that are working in like space
travel so SpaceX Blue Origin I'm like
I'm super excited for whatever is going
on there I wanted to be an astronaut
when I was little right so just the idea
that things are moving forward in terms
of like people getting
more people getting in his face I think
is really cool so I'm just always
excited for anything going on with that
I'll let like electric cars being more
affordable it's a cool thing I'd love to
get one myself at some point so trying
to think that's yeah that's probably the
tech that I'm most excited about yeah
yeah definitely and in the terms of like
coding and what I do react suspense
seems super awesome I can't wait until
that's actually like usable and like
fully production ready so alright so
that was my last question I got it I
gotta cut it off I know there's more
there's more stuff coming in but I'm
super tired so this has been a three and
a half hour livestream thank you all so
much for watching everybody in the chat
you owe or amazing felt good to be back
in in a live coding session so hopefully
I'll be doing some more like live coding
sessions
it's really tough between my job and you
know my family I don't have a lot of
time but I'm gonna do my best to try to
carve out a little bit of time and do
more of these anyway happy new year
everyone hope this is a great year for
you all and until next time let's have a
have a great have a great new year a
great new decade and thanks again for
watching